Before doing that though, let's have a quiz to check whether you remember
the basics of UML. Since we're going to talk about use cases, I want
to ask you, what is the difference between a use case and a
use case model. So here are the possible answers, and you can mark
more than one. First one is that only use case models include actors.
The second is that they are the same thing. The third one is
that a use case model is a set of use cases. The fourth
one says that a use case is a set of use case models.
Finally, the last one says that use cases
are a dynamic representation, whereas use case models
are a static representation of a system. So
mark all the answers that you think are correct.